comme ça ici vous allez pouvoir rentrer
Pierre-Luc cochon réside sur l'île merci
à une centaine de mètres de l'île
bizarres
le pont est submergé et fermé depuis
mardi il faut accéder à Lille par bateau
il y a plein de choses qui dépendent
toutes les voisins à Le Mercier que on
va se parler mais dont les gens doivent
aller travailler ramener de la
nourriture une fois sur l'île Pierre-Luc
constate que la pompe empêchant l'eau de
s'infiltrer dans les sous-sols des
maisons s'est arrêtée
insulaires depuis mardi une centaine de
personnes vivent sur l'île ils sont
préparés et habitués aux crues
printanières
s'épuisant c'est
en plus de la maison sont pas mal
sécuritaires on a juste la première avec
les ponts qui sont pas ouverte puis on
peut pas sortir d'ici
est stable depuis vendredi quelques rues
sont toujours inondées une chose qu'on
est en prévention on est vraiment
content la date on se croise les doigts
c'est pas parfait il y a des sous-sols
qui ont eu de l'eau mais là on parle pas
des impacts de 2017-2019 agatino les
niveaux se stabilisent mais une
quarantaine de rues sont toujours
inondées
près de 650 bénévoles ont participé aux
efforts de nettoyage c'est des anges
10 personnes là qui sont arrivées tout
le monde travaillait je les connais pas
je les connais pas ces gens-là c'est une
organisation hallucinante une
organisation monstre il passe il nous
donne de l'eau et nous donne des papes
séquelles ils font des sanwichs
on est brûlé on est crevé et arrive ils
mettent la musique et on nous redonne le
sourire la décrue n'arrivera pas au même
moment pour tous les résidents de l'île
merci doivent encore s'ermite patience
et attendre la réouverture de la seule
route qui les relie au reste de
l'archipel montréalais ici
Marie-Isabelle Rochon Radio-Canada à
l'île merci